bonjour à tous vous savez nous sommes
tous conviés aux urnes le 21 octobre
prochain pour se choisir un nouveau
parti qui nous représentera donc au
parlement à ottawa
alors nous nous sommes intéressés en
tant qu'espace autochtone à ce que
veulent entendre les autochtones nous
avons réunis sur le plateau des
analystes nous allons les suivre pendant
quelques semaines et ça commence
aujourd'hui
alors je vous les présente d'abord
habituellement il avait lé là donc
encore une fois isabelle picard bonjour
je également nous avons invité alexis
wawanoloath bonjour alexis mabille et
cindy world bonjour sine die en journée
alors je peux toujours vous présenter
parce que c'est toujours intéressant de
savoir d'où vous venez qui vous est dans
mon coeur si je recommence par l'autre
bout cindy vous êtes doctorante chargé
de cours à l'université du québec à
abitibi témiscamingue c'est vrai en
abitibi-témiscamingue j'allais dire à
trois rivières mais non pas du tout vos
communautés anishnabe et attikameks
voilà alexis vous êtes maintenant
juristes et vous avez quand même décidé
de continuer à étudier donc vous êtes
étudiant obama et ce qui est intéressant
de souligner évidemment c'est que vous
même vous avez fait de la politique
oui en 2005 j'ai été député à
l'assemblée nationale et en 2013 j'ai
été élu au conseil des abénakis d'odanak
ou si oui et vous êtes un abénakis
exactement et puis isabelle ethnologue
chargé de cours à l'uqam et bien sûr
wendat
voilà alors on va s'intéresser avant de
se lancer dans la nouvelle campagne
électorale puisque maintenant le
gouvernement est en élection on va
parler d'eux on va revenir en fait sur
les quatre années au pouvoir de justin
trudeau qui veut se lancer dans la mêlée
en premier pour parler de son bilan
si vous mettez un collègue
le gouvernement trudeau a fait beaucoup
d'actions symboliques
on l'a vu avec beaucoup d'excusés
beaucoup de pleurs aussi de la part de
justin trudeau est ce que c'était
sincère je l'espère mais au delà des
actions symboliques y eut aussi l'argent
frais qui a été investi dans les
communautés mais aujourd'hui on se
retrouve quand même avec la
réconciliation qui t'aime que je
n'apprécie vraiment pas qu'il est loin
d'être fait qu'il est loin d'être série
on peut voir par le cheik les questions
environnementales comme tracks mountain
ou des choses comme ça on peut le voir à
travers le fait qu'ils aient beaucoup de
communautés qui ont encore besoin de
faire bouillir la cessoie ya des grands
dossiers en fait sur lesquels on s'est
beaucoup penché au cours des quatre
dernières années que ce soit transmis
tonnes
les femmes autochtones évidemment les la
santé aussi aller les besoins de
services dans les communautés en ce qui
concerne la santé la justice et tous les
autres et puis évidemment tous les
problèmes les problèmes d'eau dans les
diverses communautés à travers le pays
il ya des promesses qui ont été presque
fait conclut en a d'autres qui sont en
chemin
est-ce qu'on devrait donner quatre
autres années aux libéraux pour terminer
leurs promesses
ça c'est une grande question en fait je
suis retombé en faisant mes recherches
sur le programme électoral de 2015 oui
on voit vraiment que c'est un programme
qui était basée sur la réconciliation
oui oui là est ce que vraiment en quatre
ans on peut réconcilier plusieurs
siècles de colonialisme c'est la grande
question c'était peut-être un peu
utopique comme programme à l'époque
comme avec les avancées mais c'est sûr
que les attentes étaient hautes ya eu
des déceptions quand même assez énorme
il ya eu des avancées on peut pas on
peut pas se le cacher si je compare avec
les 10 ans du régime harper on a quand
même fait des progrès là il ya quand
même 80 communautés 87 je crois même
qu'ils ont accès à l'eau potable
maintenant il reste une cinquantaine ont
le gouvernement libéral promet qu'en
tous vont être rattrapés de ce côté là
il ya eu
la loi sur la reconnaissance des langues
autochtones y eut la loi ici sur le
contrôle des communautés de leurs
services à l'enfance dont un portant à 6
92 donc eu des avancées il ya eu de
l'argent frais d'investir beaucoup
d'ailleurs comme alex il mentionné mais
maintenant c'est aux côtés de du côté de
la réconciliation que l'eau avec ce qui
s'est passé avec jodie avec le pipeline
le bob laisse sa peau était évidente et
mollo niang rattrapage à faire puis la
question est importante est ce qu'on
nomme encore 1 4 ans pour poursuivre sur
cet élan là où est-ce qu'on change
cindy ben en fait moi ce que je retiens
c'est la nouvelle relation tant promis
en 2015 qui est pas survenu si on
regarde aujourd'hui l'état des choses on
n'en est pas là c'est sûr qu'il ya eu
des avancées mais je lisais dans le
document de l'apn qui soumettent à des
élections qui à 76 % ou 73 % des enfants
dans les réserves qui ont pas que c'est
encore à une eau qui est sécurisée dans
le fond donc c'est quand même énorme
même si eu des avancées
la déclaration des nations unies qui a
pas été mises en oeuvre et l'eau j'en
entends qui légiférer sur le sujet fait
que je trouve ça un peu parano que ça
avec la situation comme à calais
aujourd'hui oui mais non c'est sûr il ya
eu des avancées est ce qu'on lui donne
un nom un autre mandat de quatre ans moi
je loin d'être certaine que qui va avoir
une majorité par ici voyons voir mais
c'est quoi la solution de rechange
on regarde le côté sécurisé de prendre
la place du libéro zoubir encore oui
donc si on va dans la politique du moins
pire séisme
à moins qu'ils aient un grand changement
de la part des consommateurs
non non non un envol en fait oui parce
que ça serait vers ce qui serait plus
positif pour les premières nations ici
sinon c'est vrai que en ce moment
j'entends monsieur trudeau lancé le
spectre des années harper les années
sont je pense que quand je vois cette
carte là auprès des premières nations et
joue la bonne carte mieux genre quoi je
veux pas parler pour tout le monde mais
oui je pense pas qu'il ya un truc tonnes
qui a envie de retourner à crc années
d'austérité alors le mot clé des quatre
dernières années on disait c'était
réconciliation on devrait changer par
quoi on commence une nouvelle campagne
on devrait changer ce mot-là par quoi
pour attirer les autochtones
décolonisation exactement c'est ce qu'on
est tous d'origine coloniale
le premier voudrait le prononcer il y en
a qui le prononce oui ok alors on va on
va rentrer dans le vif du sujet là je
vais rappeler qu'en 2015 des canadiens
avaient élu dix députés autochtone il y
avait eu deux néo démocrate huit
libéraux qui avait siégé à la chambre
des communes
là on parlait de l'intérêt des
autochtones je pense qu'il en est pour
l'instant il ya 38 candidats autochtones
qui se sont présentés sur les 338 sièges
à combler on sait pas combien seront
élus ce sera à suivre
d'ailleurs la période de mise en
candidature est pas tout à fait terminée
donc on va voir ce qui va se passer donc
un peu plus de gens un peu plus
autochtone qui s'intéressent à la
campagne électorale justement l'intérêt
des autochtones dans cette campagne
c'est quoi l'intérêt là actuellement si
les nouveaux prix sera les candidats on
dit l'on parle du nombre il y en a cinq
pour les conservateurs
google oui moi j'étais vraiment surpris
je sais pas vous le
oui je n'ai pas le temps d'aller comme
fouiller les candidatures édition mais
ça m'interpelle c'est ce que je suis
intéressé à aller voir un peu leurs
objets dans un temps sans intérêt par
rapport aux partis parce que le parti
quand on le lit on parlait de
décolonisation tantôt faudrait juste
commencé à décoloniser le langage du
parti conservateur qui nous appellent
les canadiens autochtones y est on peut
se questionner on peut jaser autour de
toi aussi donc le langage qui est tout
doux et leur intention évidemment le
meilleur jeu de savoir qui est ce un
candidat autochtone ça m'interpelle
et puis parlons des conservateurs je
pense que l'intérêt pour cette élection
si des autochtones c'est de ne pas
retourner en arrière dans l'air harper
finalement on a des équipes on veut pas
librement et peut-être de poursuivre cet
élan là il ya quand même quelque chose
qui qui s'était fait qui a été fait bon
moment là et puis c'est peut-être de
poursuivre sur cette lancée là je disais
que 61% des autochtones sont allés voter
en 2015
ça m'a quand même surpris c'est quand
même plus que ce que je moyens
évidemment on veut toujours plus au
fédéral qu'au provincial évidemment mais
quand même
j'espère que les autochtones
principalement à ce qu'on connaît la
carte électorale je pense que c'était
oui général c'est ça l'image ainsi
devoir pour le québec
avant de présenter non malheureusement
et qu'est ce que j'avais toujours par
rapport à ça mais en fait j'espère que
cette fois leur rouge et or dans tout
cas de voir le jour où les premières
nations ne vont pas aller voter parce
que justement ils veulent par opposition
parce qu'ils veulent bloquer quelque
chose mais qui vont vouloir aller voter
parce que vraiment il croit en quelque
chose sans télé l'instruisant et là on
n'y est pas encore l'été on est encore
dans le balbutiement de quelque chose
parce que c'est ce que ça parce qu'il
faut se dire qu'on a tous souvent
pratiqué la politique de la chaise vide
où on n'avait pas justement le droit de
vote avant c'était pas quelque chose qui
nous a interpellés et quant à eux le
droit de vote et instituts et on n'a pas
un serment participer au processus
électoral donc on était une quantité
négligeable quand on parle de chances de
se faire réélire et moi qu'est ce que je
peux constater avec mon expérience c'est
que en étant le seul autochtone à
l'assemblée nationale je suis seul qui
était l'assemblée nationale et j'espère
qu'ils vont avoir un éventuellement mais
en étant seul là-bas dès qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui concernait les
autochtones j'étais l'indien de service
que ce soit dans mon parti où que ce
soit à l'assemblée nationale j'étais au
moins est là pour dire hey attention
d'exister donc oui c'est sûr que ces
interpellations savoir qu'il ya des
candidats autochtones conservateur mais
je me dis que au moins s'y investissent
le parti comptait être capable de le
faire changer de l'intérieur
par la suite si on voit dans les sujets
qu'il y ait quelques personnellement je
trouve très important le territoire le
territoire on ne parle justement la
réconciliation les actions qui sont fait
tout ça c'est tout le temps en
reconnaissant une culture donnant plus
d'autonomie pour la gestion des services
sociaux de l'ailé gestion mais il faudra
l'arrivée un coin où on règle les
questions territoriales oui il ya eu des
certaines avancées qui ont été faits
pour les revendications particulières
mais les revendications que le bal les
revendications particulières c'est des
revendications qui se passe dans chaque
mode est où
le gouvernement omanais agit dans le
passé on peut protéger les droits des
premières nations
les revendications globales c'est les
revendications qui concernent les
territoires de chasse les grands
territoires qu'on parle du nda qui n'a
pour les abénakis où l'un est harki
nantes pour les appliquer avec par
exemple
donc je pense que on le vit les
attikameks ont déposé une volonté de se
déclarer souverain sur le territoire
comment on va actualiser ce justement
aujourd'hui comment on va faire en sorte
qu'on puisse avoir accès aux ressources
de nos territoires
le protégé aussi parce que quand on
parle de territoire va falloir aussi
parler d'environnement c'est les
communautés autochtones qui sont plus
touchés par les changements climatiques
mes amis nous et dans le nord sont
chaque fois déjà les changements par
rapport à la chasse par rapport à la
page mes amis anishnabe qui voit lequel
ebook est complètement star ac ou
l'orignal justement être en déclin donc
c'est non votre devis que son lit sont
les plus en danger par rapport aux
questions environnementales va falloir
parler de justice environnementale ou si
je pense
isabelle non pardon vous dire je les
jeux seraient jetés dans les airs
l'étude partielle des programmes qui
sont disponibles en ce moment il y avait
le npd qui reconnaissait déjà dans son
programme cette souveraineté n'est
remplie en fait c'est le npd pour le
sens qui est le programme le plus
fournir mais par rapport à
l'environnement et donc le territoire le
jeu la justice unis j'ai quand même été
heureuse de voir le chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations pour belgrade qui
est aux miss l'environnement à priori
oui absolument
franchement la reflex vraiment ce que
j'entends sur le terrain
il était temps qu'on conduisent les
choses de cette façon le picon d écouter
et cet environnement là ne peut pas se
faire justement sans cette protection de
l'environnement le finalement ne peut
pas se faire sans la connaissance et
l'utilisation des savoirs autochtones
qui oui oui oui
ça fait drôlement absolument je parlais
des amis écologistes qui travaillent
avec des zones à bis entre autres c'est
qu'ils me disent que les connaissances
des membres de la communauté sont super
look c'est justement dans l'analyse
figlarz la compréhension des dynamiques
du territoire alors lançons-nous dans
les programmes enfin le peu qu'on
connaît de chaque programme justement ce
qui n'est pas évident d'ailleurs vous
avez fait un exercice intéressant alexis
c'est à dire regardez les sites internet
des différents partis oui conservateur
je voulais voir autochtone comment
commence à 30 clips pour se rendre à
cape town cherche dans conservateur je
trouve rien click et link d'exane déclic
je trouve rien non il a fallu que je
sorte du site des conservateurs que je
retourne sur good bloc que je tape
conservateur plus autochtone et là j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un discours de monsieur
chez eux ou des choses comme ça par la
passe donc c'est très faible leur site
libérons je m'attendais à quelque chose
de vraiment à mieux de la part par
rapport à où il est question autochtone
sont soulevés mais encore la fois les
deux dans le moteur de recherche et mais
au moins on n'a pas besoin de sortir du
site
j'ai réussi à trouver qu'est-ce-qui des
engagements clés les actions qu'ils
voulaient faire
oui ils sont obligés à six sur le
programme la plateforme de change et
qu'on ne peut mieux un jour le bloc
québécois j'ai rien trouvé
ça va ça va sortir le 15
quelque chose pour un [ __ ] son appui 3
clic clic les clés j'étais vraiment
soumis aux questions autochtones et emma
vont le signer c'est bien fournir on
parle de réconciliation
bonjour moi comme je vous l'aï dit j'ai
pas attention c'est pas mon roman mon
thème préféré quand on arrive au parti
vert encore là trois clics on arrive aux
questions autochtones est il là on
arrive justement de danse et qu'est-ce
que je parle un petit peu plus tôt pitau
la sémantique des mots on parle pas de
réconciliation on part de pression des
autochtones
combative on parle de décolonisation de
sortir du colonialisme
donc je trouve que par rapport à
l'utilisation qu'ils démons le parti
vert est celui qui fait moins de
féminisme c'est le qui était du moins
notre réalité à quelque chose quand même
de plus pu comme on peut le voir dans
d'autres partis on adresse vraiment le
problème on dit que tu colonialiste que
des pressions j'apprécie quand même
c'était d'ailleurs c'est celui qu'on
voit à l'écran actuellement oui ce que
j'ai trouvé intéressant comme suit
trudeau a lancé la campagne c'est que
par rapport à 2015 en 2015 les
autochtones c'était sa priorité numéro
un
la peau pas un monde dont les
autochtones dans son discours il a
appelé à aider la classe moyenne les
familles les parents monoparentales et
cetera
pas un mot sur les autochtones alors là
moi ça me ça m'a énormément marqué j'ai
regardé aussi au niveau des
conservateurs j'ai fait un peu le même
exercice
est ce que j'ai pu voir c'est que les
conservateurs ont l'air d'être dans la
même lignée corps peut alors il faut il
faut se passer le message il pose pas
seulement au tac autochtone c'est un peu
c'est un peu ce qu'on voyait ne paraît
pas au niveau de l'énergie et voilà
c'est tout ce que j'ai pu voir et dans
les rangs des comme toi d'action
conception c'est cette logique loca
derrière ces trois lettres sont
enclenchées dans des noues des cons il
faut savoir lire entre le npd oui c'est
beaucoup plus complet quand même je
trouve ça intéressant comme comme
programme mettre fin à la crise du
logement dont ils ont compris ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai pas vu ailleurs
évidemment au niveau de l'eau sont un
peu comme les libéraux mettent fin à
vent en fête de l'eau potable pour tous
d'ici fin 2021 mettre en place le plan
d'action pour la réconciliation bon
oui et l'anfa d'or bien sûr donc pour
une femme autochtone donc ça c'était
quelque chose que j'ai vu leur que j'ai
pas vraiment vu ailleurs et ça ça
m'interpelle est grandement évidemment
le parti vert bain avec tout ce qui est
en vironnement bon j'ai terrain comme je
trouve qu'il utilise les mots il met les
points sur les i et les barres sur les t
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant au
niveau de la proche du parti vert je
pense qu'il est temps que si on veut
avoir une vraie réconciliation
je le dis à mes livres je pense qu'il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont et
le npd 14 candidats quand même
autochtone je les ai comptés ce matin
mais c'est sage et réaliste et si oui en
fait je pense que c'est le pour
l'instant c'est le npd qui a le plus de
candidats autochtones
ok oui d'après les deux libérés
probablement dit des libéraux en effet
et je me suis amusé un peu ch aller voir
le parti populaire oui des fois
donc ben saada entend pas beaucoup de
rendez rendre les canadiens plus riches
rien par rapport aux autochtones cas
qu'on parle de richesses en bresse on
pense à l'exploitation du territoire des
femmes les canadiens dans les zones
rurales je vais bien mais les
autochtones souvent elles et les
communautés sont éloignés absolument pas
un mot sur les autochtones là-dessus
libérer le potentiel économique du
canada rien et politiques d'armes à feu
rita brillé non plus pas plus rien donc
gg déclic et tout ça il y avait pas
grand chose là ce que j'ai mis par
exemple dans le bloc même si c'était la
plateforme de 2015 et 20 petites phrases
dont les multiples qui reconnaissait
dans le fond jusque séjourna minutes on
a tout à gagner a établi des
partenariats le québec et le canada ont
été bâtis sur un territoire déjà occupé
par les premières nations les inuits
on ne peut imaginer construire le québec
sans ces nations et sans tenir compte de
leur culture c'était écrit dans d'entrée
de jeu sur la plateforme de 2008 il a un
ça va mais je trouvais que c'était une
belle prémices je ne sais pas où ça va
revenir dans la nouvelle plateforme
j'ose espérer j'ose espérer par rapport
à l'environnement à l'exploitation du
territoire aussi avec les revendications
en ce moment qu'ils ont dans notre dans
notre province
je pense que le québécois peut pas faire
fi de leurs affirmations en fils
et je sais que monsieur blanchet
consulter quand même des membres des
premières nations dont pour leur
demander comment est ce que je peux
aider qu'est-ce que je peux faire c'est
quoi vos priorités dont il ya quand même
le dialogue s'est instauré
on verra qui commence à se transpose
commandant la plateforme peut avoir
quelque chose est-ce que ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs pour les autres partis est ce
qui a eu des consultations avaient vite
avez vous été au fait des approches des
différents sports répond non au niveau
des libéraux je sais qu'il ya quelques
députés qui ont rencontré dénouement
mais c'est beau le chef nécessairement
c'est au niveau des députés ou des
candidats en fait mais j'en sais pas
plus pour les autres partis d'accord
vous alliez ajouté apparemment loblaw
qui serait incohérent de la part des
nationalistes québécois de reconnaître
alors normalement évidemment les
programmes vont se remplir de plus en
plus cela qui a le plus intérêt à
s'intéresser aux enjeux autochtones
si on voit que la priorité de
l'environnement de l'apn ce serait le
parti vert à mon avis en ce moment avec
le programme disponible
qu'est ce que vous en pensez wilma qui
quels moyens terrestres que c'est sûr
chez les conservateurs dont hull on est
une quantité négligent puis je pense pas
qu'ils ont repris un espoir de voir 2
octobre votez pour eux dans les
realpolitik
ces libéraux qui se bat pour garder le
pouvoir donc eux ont tout intérêt à les
chercher un long tapis si les libéraux
ont été élus la dernière élection dans
bien des régions
les u9 vote autochtone a été déterminant
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il va avoir
est-ce qu'on va voter pour la politique
du moment les pays où on va voter avec
notre coeur qui sont plus vives à loulou
avait des séquelles et et qui va être je
pense une question importante est de
voir dans son côté si on a un
conservateur kenneth de l'entrée est ce
qu'on va faire le choix pratique ou le
choix qui vont avec noir
je pense que tous les partis ont
avantage à travailler avec les
autochtones à avoir dans leur plate
forme des éléments clés des éléments
forts qui vont venir aider la relation
entre le gouvernement fédéral le canada
et les premières nations parce qu'on est
partout sur le territoire
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque chose
que ce soit au niveau du développement
économique des revendications
territoriales de l'utilisation de la
langue dans les langues officielles et
cetera on est on est partout puis on se
fait de plus en plus entendre donc je
pense que tout le monde a intérêt à ce
qu'on puisse travailler ensemble jeu
malheureusement les conservateurs jeu
j'espère en tout cas parce que dans dans
les discours on est complètement absent
c'est quand même un parti on voit que
les sondages sont au coude à coude entre
les libéraux et les conservateurs
présentement
donc il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose à ce niveau là je peux pas croire
est ce que ça veut dire que les
premières nations vont aller dans ce
sens le nom je crois pas parce qu'on a
encore l'héritage un peu en mémoire mais
ils doivent travailler un petit peu leur
programme pour nous il y inclure sait
pas trop si bien puisque les programmes
ne sont pas complétés vous êtes là
dites-leur quoi ajouter je me posais la
question la question de l'homme juste à
main mais j'essaie d'abord par laquelle
on entendait j'ai été interpellé et ça
peut toucher après tout en faire mais
c'est quand même j'écoutais la première
journée elle a lancé la campagne et
c'est vrai qu'on est absent des discours
je me demande elle et les parties en ce
moment nous situer où c'est comme j'ai
l'impression que quelques parties marche
les yeux en ce moment ils savent pas où
nous situer moi je pense qu'en prenant
les priorités de l'apn en ce moment ce
serait déjà
un bon aiguillage à mon avis en mettant
l'environnement en priorité mais aussi
toutes les situations au niveau des
infrastructures
on parlait de l'eau potable tantôt mais
le logement et je lisais dans leur
programme qu'une personne sur 15
autochtone qui veut bien vivre en milieu
urbain avec des itinéraires
puis le jeu sont sans voix vers les
logements surpeuplés et dont il attend
du coup c'est assez alarmant donc je
pense qu'en lisant les priorités de
l'apn ça serait des jours de les
intégrer dans leurs programmes ce serait
déjà un bon point à mon avis mme alix si
vous avez voulu re demanderiez d'ajouter
quoi les jeux vont porter de casque à
casque et deux par deux jeunes filles
qui veulent avoir un avenir pour m
on s'en va dans le mur en ce moment en
tant que civilisation où il nous
resterait 12,1 à pour âgées pour que
notre planète ne devienne connais-tu
donc 6e on parle beaucoup
d'environnement mais ici c'est l'opeeci
les premières nations qui sont les
premières premier touch est ce parce
donc bien lieu bien le dit on le dit ça
devrait être une priorité
il faudrait pas parler des deux côtés de
la bouche comme on le voit avec les
numéros ou avec de pareils transmis le
thème je met ma casquette de l'oif j
aime beaucoup la constitution je pense
que on emule pour une réforme
constitutionnelle
en ce moment les autochtones sont des
sujets du gouvernement fédéral
moi j'aimerais qu'on devient un acteur
fédéral au même titre que les provinces
et je pense que l'oeuf lui est plus que
mû pour qu'on peut savoir une vraie
reconnaissance justement changer cette
constitution le t2 premièrement prendre
en ville non sens d'avoir une reine
d'angleterre qui viennent être notre
chef d'état
et on pourrait en profiter ou si
justement pour inclure
les premières nations dans un palier
gouvernement pour que nos communautés
puissent avoir leur mot à dire sur la
territoire leur mot à dire sur leur
développement
et je pense que c'est pas injuste par
rapport à nos communautés ça serait pour
les sociétés canadiennes en général la
société québécoise les sociétés
canadiennes
ça pourrait être bon aussi du fait qu'on
pourrait aller prendre aux valeurs entre
autres le point focus à la philosophie
de la majorité des nations autochtones
si le territoire est ici on prendrait
justement au lieu de prendre la liberté
commerce à liberté comme on l'entend le
mot libéral et le temps qu'un point fort
q cells philosophique aussi en prenez le
territoire puis on se donnait des
responsabilités nous sommes partis de ce
territoire leur le territoire nous
appartient pas son renverserait
justement les perspectives pour
l'inscrire est directement dans la
constitution
bon ben on pourrait justement avoir une
responsabilité environnementale pour
avoir des droits environnementaux qui
pour être plus fort donc je pense que ça
va être tout est priorité de repas pour
lesquelles on a parlé sont pressantes
c'est sûr qu'il manque de place pour les
gens dans les communautés c'est sûr que
le système de justice est pas adapté on
y roule trouvent représentées dans les
crises en mai va falloir justement aller
à la source de tout ce problème là je
pense que seule la source de problèmes
ça va se régler par une réforme
constitutionnelle n'est pas le parti car
le processus
isabelle j'ai noté trois priorités
l'environnement l'environnement
l'environnement je suis je suis plus
capable aujourd'hui de parler même la
cause autochtone sans parler de
l'environnement puisque comme alex il
disait ça nous touche dans un premier
temps et d'en donner convient le
territoire et ça je l'ait pas entendu
tant que ça dans les discours un peu
métier qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est
toujours l'environnement c'est toujours
la belle chose à dire en premier mais
les all blacks ne suit ne vivent pas non
deuxième chose la guérison et leur je
parle de mettre en place toutes les
recommandations de la commission vérité
réconciliation du rapport de l'igf ada
également ça on en a pas beaucoup
entendu parler cet été je sais que
seulement été déposée le 3 juin
oui mais j'ai rencontré la commissaire
michel audet dernièrement et puis je
m'en débarrasse en est où place du vélo
il se pense pas grand chose
il ya les élections tout ça il faut que
c'est regarder absolument
trop souvent les rapports il ya eu
plusieurs commissions et comme son
enquête
comme si royal enquête et chez terreur
par rapport aux autochtones il a été
tabletté beaucoup trop souvent je pense
que ce qu'il faut c'est que les
recommandations soient mises en action
tout de suite et il faut surtout qu'il y
ait des résultats palpables dans les
communautés auprès des autochtones
eux-mêmes souvent ça s'arrête à un
certain niveau puis on dit bon on a fait
ce qu'il fallait non il faut qu'il faut
agir jusqu'à temps qu'il y ait des
résultats dans les communautés palpable
et auprès des premières nations or comme
noter également donc cet aspect guérison
l'homme à part extrêmement important et
la troisième c'est encore on parle
toujours la même chose aux gens un peu
alexis mais une relation de nation à
nation réel je pense pas que ça a été
atteint avec avec tout doux même si avec
monsieur trudeau même s'il y avait
beaucoup de d'espoir et de bons mots et
de je pense qu'on n'a pas réussi à se
rendre jusque là il faut trouver un
moyen c'est peut-être un moyen ce que tu
mentionnes y en a peut-être d'autres
mais réellement il faut qu'on soit
considéré pour ce qu'on est comme
première nation premier premiers
habitants du territoire
parce qu'on parle de souveraineté
partagée en ce moment les gardes des
arrêts de la cour suprême en étau se
définit par son territoire et
la population que des composants
principal
si on veut vraiment parler de
souveraineté partagée sur le territoire
falloir que les premières nations soient
inclus nadal qui a vraiment leur mot à
dire tu es par l'appartenance mon thème
plutôt que disait que les premières
nations à les avoir si disais non ça va
être un nom va donc s'alléger semelle
comme un droit de veto donc aujourd'hui
10 puis la même chose il dit non
d'ailleurs ce matin c'est là où c'est le
moment pendant les quatre dernières
années où j'ai senti que ça se corse
je me souviens quand j'ai lu la nouvelle
j'ai senti comme un ver concassés sur le
sol sur de la céramique j'ai senti que
la relation était brisée tient
absolument à aider je comprends tout le
politique l'économique qui entoure tout
ça mais au niveau de la relation avec
les premières nations les premiers
peuples
d'après moi ça a été vraiment - pour
marquer un point tournant et sa diviser
les premières nations
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on serait
alliée de [ __ ] jones mountain
c'est vraiment comme ça divisées et ça
se sait rien d'un évidemment donc je
pense que l'on va voir ils vont être
entendus finalement leur appel j'ai hâte
de voir la suite mais moi aussi j'ai
senti vraiment que c'est là qu'il ya eu
une brisure au niveau de la confiance au
niveau du lien qui avait avec les
autochtones le parti libéral jusqu'à ce
moment là puis pour faire un peu de peau
ce que vous disiez moi je pense que peu
importe le parti qui vont rentrer je
pense que celui qui peut aller chercher
un peu les vote autochtone c'est celui
qui va honorer les relations qui ont été
établis entre qui ont tenté d'être
établie depuis le début qui est
tellement tellement du seul atteindront
même les autochtones et il le
verbalisent très bien on ne les reverra
à prononcer le mot réconciliation c'est
comme une lassitude autour de sommes
donc il faut redéfinir cette relation la
nasa nation évidemment ces
réconciliations ce qui se fait de mieux
comme une marque de commerce
oui
envie de son envie absolument oui et
puis tant attendu par led et la justice
mais de revenir un peu au système
traditionnel de justice autochtone on
avait nos modes qui fonctionne et les
autochtones veulent se réapproprier son
on le voit avec la cia 92 et ça donc je
pense de faire une plus grande confiance
à ce niveau-là de un peulh et le chaos
de l'origine de notre loi actuelle pour
s'ouvrir la façon de penser autochtones
je pense qu'on irait chercher des
résultats on va le voir avec la
protection de la jeunesse mais au niveau
du justus système de justice pénale on
engorge le système que ce soit carcéral
au niveau de justice pénale largement
donc je pense qu'on a intérêt à aller
sonder d'autres façons de faire
puis qu'ils vont tous est bonne pour les
autochtones finalement pour toutes les
sociétés canadiennes de s'inspirer
justement que ce soit en et
environnement mais que ce soit celle du
cirque injustice comme un bon on regarde
quelqu'un d'un communauté malgré tout
malgré qu'ils soient toxicomanes malgré
qui a des problèmes qui des choses comme
ça les études le démontrent en général
celui qui sont exclus même qu'ils
réussissent à garder des liens sociaux
vont sûrement survivent convoi avoir
plus de chance qui s'est pas juste par
rapport à la toxicomanie et des
criminels
comment on fait pour justement la
réintégration il des du cercle ça
pourrait accuser le poids juste pour les
premières nations
on commence à le montrer de plus en plus
une cour de justice sont autochtones qui
a été instaurée en alberta a calé à quoi
sert ce n'est aussi la justice civile
c'est intéressant par exemple par
l'exemple que vous donniez au manitoba
où deux femmes blanches ont posté des
commentaires racistes sur internet
par la suite la cour supérieure de cette
province a décidé de référé au tribunal
at acteurs oui moi pour un espace g le
pilote ça a été justement des s'était
pas définition de c'était de faire du
travail communautaire et à les suivre
des cours sur les réalités intacte pour
justement aider à comprendre la réalité
et réparation des réparations exactement
alors tous les trois vous habitez en
ville donc des politiciens et vous allez
sûrement revoir qui vont venir cogner à
votre porte vont ils aller cogner aux
portes dans les communautés va-t-on les
voir sur le territoire de dans les
communautés est ce que c'est le cas
habituellement est à la fois la ville et
dans ma communauté un voyage en eux et
dans les dernières élections ce que j'ai
vu c'est des rassemblements donc il ya
un candidat
je pense que c'est aux élections
provinciales mais bon peut-être
confédéral c'est la même chose je me
souviens plus trop mais qui s'annonce et
qui dit bon exemple 2 octobre je vais
être à la salle tel salsa le court 10e
ronde en salle communautaire
oui et venez me rencontrer donc ça ça se
fait j'ai pas vu j'ai jamais vu dans ma
vie des candidats qui cognait aux portes
peut-être que ça sera cette fois-ci et
j'ai habité longtemps qu'elle n'ait
s'attaquer et encore moins là évidemment
il ya des communautés où malheureusement
on veut pas aller et c'est ce dialogue
locke qui me dérange beaucoup
il faut forcer les choses d'un côté
comme de l'autre parce que il ya des
candidats qui me disait ben j'essaie
d'aller rencontrer un chef tel chef et
le chef veut pas voir mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut commencer un dialogue
si on n'est pas capables de se parler
oui si j'ai un appel à faro chef
aujourd'hui c'est ça on peut tout au
moins écouté puis commencer à échanger
je pense que c'est la base
personnellement je vais aller voir les
communautés quand j'étais je m'étais
présenté à val-d'or en temps un petit
billet donc j'allais voir les conseils
de bande qui j'en profitais pour
rencontrer la communauté qu'est ce que
j'ai vu à odanak et de la part des
candidats fédéraux c'est qu'ils venaient
aux activités communautaires ou des
choses comme ça où
mais j'ai jamais vu aucun de mes jeunes
amis que oui un candidat npd qui était
venu cogner à sa porte al dabbagh est-ce
qu'ils vont se rendre jusqu à pikogan
jusqu'à wiimote alchimie ou à faire au
match et je peux pas répondre pikogan
oui à des rassemblements et ça pour
l'instant je ne sais pas je veux pas
parler à tort mais je me suis amusé à
faire un petit sondage comme ça ça nous
met communauté voire sur les intentions
de vote avant les intérêts les voter
c'est sûr que ces maisons là mais quand
même la majorité avait l'intention
d'aller voter avec des indécis qui en
avait carrément non mais de l'ordre de
80% dans ce mini sondage avec j'invite
vraiment les parties à se déplacer puis
oui allez expliquer leur programme
maintenant il ya des tensions est-ce que
tu sentais que les gens voulaient aller
voter pour empêcher josep à ce moment si
on n'a pas toutes les programmes et tout
ça puis je n'ai pas partir et qu parti
pris en fait maintenant je les chasse
avoir l'intention est ce qu'on est
encore dans les intentions de vote nous
les autochtones est ce qu'on a un
intérêt à oui parce qu'en fait en 2015
bon après les années harper on en avait
besoin d'un vent de changement d'un
souffle nouveau
alors il ya peut-être eu cet intérêt là
maintenant on parlait de promesses
brisées
donc est ce que les autochtones vont
avoir un désintérêt parce qu'ils disent
de toute façon il se passe pas grand
chose pour nous là ça change pas notre
vie jusqu'à prendre un peu plus le oui
oui mais quand je disais tantôt c'est 80
pour effacer plusieurs siècles de
colonialisme il faut quand même être
patient je pense qu'on est capable on le
sait en les premières nations les
premiers peuples d'être patient l'a déjà
été dans le passé il ya quand même des
grandes choses qui ont été faits on va
pas se le cacher dans les quatre
dernières années
peut-être qu'au contraire les gens
voient mais ces sites web peut-être que
l'on n'est plus présent peut-être qu'on
est capable de faire
différence de faire un changement
pourquoi pas l'apn disait que aux
dernières élections en 2015 les premiers
peuples première nation avait fait une
différence dans 22 circonscriptions
alors peut-être que là ça sera d'abord
j'avais osé mais qui n'y avait vraiment
une donnée là dessus donc 22
circonscriptions sur 338 c'est que ça
alors là si on y voit encore plus
je sais que les jeunes en tout cas ce
que je peux dire j'ai une quarantaine
d'années et les plus jeunes
moi j'allais pas voter quand j'avais 20
ans aujourd'hui je sens nettement un
intérêt de la part des plus jeunes il
veut faire bouger les choses
ils veulent ils veulent changer les
choses un peu comme dans l'esprit de ce
que tu disais think in all of the box
penser en dehors de la boire et ça ça
peut être intéressant à ce niveau là
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on a des
chiffres plus importants au niveau du
taux de votation sur les premières
nations depuis quelques tomes de
circonscription ça peut vouloir dire mal
je veux faire la différence
absolument alors là j'ai des devoirs
pour vous vous allez écouter les débats
à il arrive si bissière radio canada ce
sera les 7 et 10 octobre donc on va se
revoir le 11 octobre
et là on en saura plus évidemment sur
les plates formes de chacun des partis
on les aura entendu débattre auront-ils
prononcer le mot autochtone in des jeans
on préfère le petit des gangs au tableau
tout ça donc on se revoit le 11 octobre
pour en parler
merci à tous les 3 6 ans léonie fait et
donc pas d'émissions la semaine
prochaine ni la suivante on va suivre ce
qui se passe sur le terrain on va suivre
cette campagne électorale et on se
retrouve le 11 octobre pour un autre
espace autochtone en direct à bientôt
merci
[Musique]